okay so I'm gonna start talking about
the second part of the data wrangling
normalization and pre-processing of text
which is a follow up of the talk given
by Professor pecan two weeks ago in
which he expressed the deep learning
methods that are used to process the
signal so clinical and cephalic gruffy
or aegs as i'm gonna call it from known
is known to be the most important
investigation in the diagnosis and
management of epilepsies an energy
requires the electrical activity along
the scalp and measures spontaneous
electrical activity of the brain and for
that it is the main test for brain
related illnesses in my talk I'm going
to show how along with the eg signals
we're processing the eg reports which
are documenting the interpretation of
these signals so I'm gonna show the
kinds of methods that I used in order to
process the clinical text in the EEG
reports so data wrangling is defined as
the process of mapping data from an
instructor format in this case the
narratives or the eg reports to another
format that enables automatic processing
and in this talk today we're going to
see see how that format is basically a
very complex annotation schema that
enables us to do two kinds of processing
one to organize the information complex
probabilistic graph that would enable
probabilistic inference and the other
one on which I'm gonna focus more is in
representing this eg reports and the
signals into multimodal index that would
enable us to perform identification of
patient cohorts so the ability to
process the narratives in electronic
medical records which are now collected
in every hospital in the country
would also give rise to identification
of a staggering wealth of biomedical
knowledge this knowledge will be
inferred not only from the unstructured
text but also from many mild
measurements such as vital signs or
multi-channel signal data as in our case
is provided by the eg signals so we
believe that this information could be
transformative if properly harnessed so
as I'm going to be focusing mostly on
processing the clinical test we are
going to see that current
state-of-the-art natural language
processing need to be enhanced with deep
learning methods that face the
challenges which are posed by the
complexity and the volume of big data
repositories of medical records so I'm
going to show how combining the
advantages of two kinds of learning
namely active and deep learning will be
able to process a large collection of
edge reports and annotate with clinical
concepts and their attributes which will
enable us to create a specific qualified
medical knowledge graph and also to be
able to use that for medical inference
like estimations of likelihoods of the
clinical correlations or interpretation
of the EEG test and also in the
discovery of patient cohorts now when we
talk about clinical text mining this has
been done for many decades and there's
ample research that can be distinguished
in mining the biomedical literature for
instance trying to find medical concepts
medical journals medical textbooks and
scholarly research reports or in other
case mining the clinical notes for
instance radiology reports progress
notes surgical notes for hospital
discharge summaries these two kinds of
clinical text mining are quite difficult
different because the first one focuses
on biomedical NLP that extracts genes or
proteins or pathways
and biomedical events and relations
which gives an opportunity for
translational work in biomedical natural
language processing with other words
getting results from the biological
domain into the clinical domain when we
perform clinical NLP were actually
focusing on building profiles of
individual patients by extracting a
broad class of medical concepts and
conditions for instance the disease's
the injuries or the symptoms and science
as well as responses like the diagnosis
procedures treatments and drugs and the
goal here is to improve patient care
so the talk today will focus on clinical
NLP processing I want to point out
another specialized special case of
performing clinical an LP which is for
adding computerized clinical decision
support and there's an excellent article
authored by dr. Dina tenor who snore
when the chapman and Clem Donald that is
offering an excellent survey the title
is in title the title of this article is
what can natural language processing do
for clinical decision support well let's
look what are the steps of clinical and
classical natural language processing of
electronic medical records and we see we
first need to identify what are the
medical concepts that we want to
annotate or discover in the medical
records in addition because this
narratives in medical records are often
using hedges we need to identify the
assertions are these medical concepts
factual or are they negated are they
expressing some hypotheses after we
identify the medical concepts and infer
the assertions the next step is to
discover the features that would enable
us to recognize them automatically the
features are informing some classifiers
that will be trained
and be able to annotate automatically
the medical concepts in records the
results of this classifiers
also need to be evaluated and the cycle
continues well there's very interesting
work and excellent resources on
discovering medical records and natural
language processing and there was a
challenge in 2010 for instance that
aimed at recognizing automatically in
records medical problems medical tests
and treatments so we want you to take
advantage of this past work and
understand that recognizing such
concepts involve two decisions first of
all you need to identify the boundaries
of this concept with other words what is
the first word in the narrative where
the concept is mentioned and what is the
last word and after you recognize the
boundaries well what kind of medical
concepts have we recognized with other
words what's the tied classification is
it a problem is it a test or is it a
treatment so the problem is and the
challenges that were facing when we need
to annotate big data is that this time
were having to annotate many more times
there are resources that perform
wonderfully for instance it takes that
would identify in medical records any
concept that is annotated in the unified
medical language system however there is
not coverage for any kind or eg related
medical concepts there so we have to go
and look at other annotations that we
can provide for this specific type of
Records as many more types of medical
concepts will need to be discovering
between that would infer that we'll have
to have a
large number of classifiers and that
poses an incredible challenge because
those classifiers will need to have some
optimal feature selection and it is very
difficult to do that throughout a large
number of classifiers so the solution
comes from deep learning and active
learning and by combining deep learning
active learning
we're actually generating can multitask
active learning paradigm it aims to
perform concurrently other multiple
annotations of all the eg activities and
their attributes or the each events or
the medical problems medical tests and
medical treatments that are encountered
in the eg reports well what are each
activities these are brain activities
such as waves and patterns and what are
each events these are brain responses as
direct result of a specific sensory
cognitive or event in addition with the
identification of every medical concept
of these types who want to identify
their mortality and polarity values what
are the possible values of modality it's
actual possible or proposed which
indicate whether that clinical concept
is an actual finding or is it a possible
finding or a finding that may be true at
some point in time in the future and
polarity has a value by the positive or
negative on the lower hand side of the
type of the circle the slide you are
seeing that basically the annotations
that were performing are multiple types
and for instance in the case of an
annotation for an activity each activity
such as rhythm we have a lot of
attributes like this is a rhythm or with
a frequency band of alpha and it is
located in both hemispheres and it is
recurring continuously and the location
is occipital and the modalities factual
and the polarity is positive
so with this I am exemplifying the
complexity of the many types on the many
attributes that we need to annotate in a
set of very large number of them eg
record revenue report so what's in an
energy report when an Ag report is
created it was the American clinical
neurophysiology Society guidelines for
writing such reports it has to start
with a section on the clinical history
describing the patient age gender and
the relevant medical conditions and
medications then an introduction section
is discussing the EEG technique or
configuration by a description of the
notable waveforms activities patterns or
age events from the signal then a
mandatory section is the impression
which is interpretation whether the EEG
indicates normal or abnormal brain
activity and the list of the
contributing ability form phenomena and
it ends with a clinical correlation
section which relates the findings with
the overall clinical patient picture so
when annotating a big data of each
reports we had to create a schema such
that we could describe all the semantics
of the EEG activities and events as they
are discussed in the report so the first
question that we had to answer was well
what medical concept we read not need to
annotate them what are there times we
decided validate medical problems
treatments and lists as well as eg
activities and events and you see here
our first example for instance if in the
clinical history were reading recently
seizure-free but with episodes of light
flashing in her peripheral vision or by
a blurry vision vision and headaches we
want to be able to annotate the fact
that seizure is a medical problem as
well as episodes of light flashing in
her peripheral vision is a medical
problem as you see this province or this
medical card
sets can be mentioned as a single word
scissor or sequence of words like in
episodes of life flashing in her
peripheral vision in the following
section topamax is identified as a
treatment now when we go to the
description of the record we're seeing
that sharply control delt activity is
actually an EEG activity so is spike
complex but around these activities we
have a lot of other attributes that are
expressed like the fact that the
supplicant or delt activity is frankly
predominant and it is irregular so we
need to capture also these attributes or
the EEG activities in our annotation
schema as we know that the eg activities
are not mentioned always in continuous
expressions we decided to use a schema
in which we will annotate the anchors
for these activities and the attributes
will be determined as a power what kind
of attributes we decided to capture well
we decided to capture a very large
number of attributes the most notable
one is the morphology the morphology
represents the type or form of the eg
leaves you see here that on the right
hand side of the slide I'm showing the
semantic hierarchy of the values that
express the morphology of the eg
activities they are classified as
ribbons they may be transient they may
be a single wave like for instance
wicked spikes they may be complex and as
complex waveforms they may be spike and
sharp wave complexes or sudden slow wave
complexes but they can also express a
large variety of patterns like a
suppression or like a periodic lateral
Lives epileptiform discharges the
morphology is just one of the attributes
along with several others that describe
the general attributes will also have
temple attributes and special attributes
that we want to annotate the frequency
band represent the second attribute that
one with it they distinguish whether the
waveform is an alphabet a delta or our
gamma form we also want to annotate
whether this is in the background or not
and as general attribute was so I
noticed separately the magnitude which
describes the amplitude of the each
activity among the tempo attributes we
are annotating the recurrence showing
how often the each activity occurs and
the possible values eyes continues
repeated or if it is none that means
that it occurs only once the G
activities are also associated with
significant number of spatial attributes
and they are grouped in three categories
the first category is the dispersal
attributes which describe the spread of
the activity over regions of the brain
could be localized or generalized
the second type of special attributes
are the hemisphere where it occurs could
be right left over and finally in a
finer spatial brain the brain location
which has another number of attributes
describing whether its frontal super
tall and so forth so as you see we have
a total of 16 attributes that are
associated with each eg activity which
makes for a very complex semantics of
the annotation schema so how do these
annotations look like in this slide
you'll see an example of the manual
annotations of the eg reports that we
have performed to create training data
for our deep learning architectures in
this example you see two types of
annotations the blue annotations
represent the boundaries for instance
multiple sclerosis indicate that that is
a mention of medical concepts in rare do
you see the axe
type of the medical concept so here we
see it's multiple sclerosis is a medical
problem it is having the modality of
factual and it is having the polarity of
positive but please note when we go into
the introduction section how the
annotations become more complex because
for instance in the case of the EEG
activities like spike and wave
discharges in red we see all these
values of the various attributes that
are associated with it that need to be
annotated like the morphology is
transient it is a context wave in the
form of spike and slow wave complex with
a frequency band of Delta with not in
the background with the magnitude normal
the recurrence is repeated the disperses
is generalized we don't have information
about the hemisphere but we have
information about the location is being
formal and model is factual and the
polarity is positive I want to note that
in this annotation we're actually making
sure that we are attacking two important
text processing problem namely ambiguity
and the economy city of text ambiguity
means that we may have one annotation
that may end up expressing different
semantic points in the hierarchy and
economic city means that in this
specific eg report there is no place
where it's indicated that this is a
frequency band of Delta that we need to
infer because later on were basically
seeing that notation is from four to
four point five Hertz so you see it's a
very complex annotation schema that
tries to capture the wealth of semantic
information that is described in the eg
report so let's see how we can create
some machine learning architectures that
would enable us to automatic
annotates a very large corpus of VG
reports following the schema first of
all we need to pre-process the eg
reports because there's many very
important resources for medical language
processing out there so we use the Genea
resources which comprise at agra fort
organization organization means
identifying a reward in the narrative
limit ization which means every word is
transformed into its base lemma form the
part of speech which recognized and that
this word is a noun and this was a verb
and so forth as well as phrase chunking
which means how the words are
grammatically sticking together in a
phrase also used a widely popular
resource which is the Stanford coronal
p4a detecting syntactic dependency
parsing in addition because every token
or word in the eg reports or identify we
created brown cluster features from the
entire Temple University Hospital corpus
the broth clustering is an unsupervised
learning method that discovered
hierarchal hierarchical classes awards
based on the context in which they occur
we also made use of the unified medical
language system to create feature vector
representations that capture the medical
knowledge that is available from the
system then we have decided on two
groups of features the first group will
be used in the deep learning
architectures that identify the eg
activity anchors as well as the
boundaries of the each event medical
problems medical tests and medical
treatments we have decided on seven
different features the first one would
be the lemma of the token and the
previous and the next tokens the second
feature is the proto speech of the
current token and its previous and next
token the third feature is the phrase
chunk in
the token belongs the fourth one is the
lemma of the current previous and next
token we made use of a feature that
represents the brown cluster in which
the token is situated then the umls
concept unique identifier for that token
and the title and the section of the eg
report where the token is observed in
order to detect the eg concept type the
attributes the many attributes of the eg
activities as well as the eg concept
modality and polarity we decided on
another set of 9 features which are
listed here the clinical concept
mentioned ulemas of each token the part
of speech the lemmas of the three tokens
before and after the title of the
section but this time also used
syntactic dependency pass the number of
words between the clinical concept
mention and the specific token the
number of hops in the syntactic
dependency pack as well as the number of
clinical concepts between the clinical
conception and the token in question so
that correspond to that block in the
natural language processing cycle in
which we had to decide on the features
that best represent the clinical concept
that we want to annotate in a vast
resource of Records ok so once that we
have the features we have to go on the
side on the deep learning architectures
weeks ago professor picanha discussed a
lot about the art and the magic that is
involved in deciding on the best
architectures that you want to use deep
learning is the preferred natural
language the preferred machine learning
techniques that can be used in the face
of very large collections of text in our
case of a big resource of eg reports so
here I'm going to start discussing the
first architectures that we use to
identify
pterence and to identify the angles of
the eg activities the boundaries were
identified for the eg events the medical
problems the tests and the treatments so
in order to decide the architecture that
is best suited to be able to learn how
to automatically identify these bangers
and anchors we have decided to use two
architectures one for the eg active
tankers and the second one for the
boundaries of the other types of medical
concepts that we were aiming to annotate
this architectures as you see on the
slide I represented by stacked long
short-term memory cells and they are
stuck because they are having several
layers and we represent it in this
architecture as entries all the tokens
is if you want it with the 3 T and
corresponds to the tokens every sentence
in any set section of the eg report the
output of the architecture are these
labels b1 to be a1 label bi is
associated with the token ti the label
values are i/o or be a level of B
indicates that this word is the
beginning of a mention of a clinical
concept a level of AI indicates that
this word or token is inside the mention
of the clinical concept and the label or
indicates that this word is outside any
kind of clinical concept that we want to
in to annotate so let's go a little bit
in more detail on how this deep
architecture the neural architecture
actually work so by considering each of
the tokens in each sentence we want to
predict the labels that they should be
associated with therefore we have a
vector representation of a very token
from the
sentence you might be asking yourself
what is in this vector representation
every token is associated to it with all
the features that we have decidable one
to use so there are the pitch of values
for that specific token and what is the
output that is values for the labels in
out or beginning of a medical console I
want to know I want to know the fact
that each of the long four terms memory
serves in this architecture is also
using a memory state that is shared
throughout the network for instance on
the first layer the lsdm cell receives
an input from the vector of the token so
let's take token number two
that vector will be input to that lsdm
cell which also touches input the memory
from the previous lsdm cell and produces
an output which becomes an input to the
next layer and so forth so we have such
three layers that make sure that they
are propagating all the features from
the current token as well as the
previous tokens to the softmax layers
that decides the labels that should be
associated with every word so we use
these three labels and on the soap max
layer we're actually producing a
probability distribution all the
possible labels of values i om b and
this is accomplished using a vector of
all the probabilities of a label to be
an i or a label to be an all or a label
to be a B therefore the softmax layer is
predicting what is the highest
probability over a label this should be
associated with that book
so this architecture enables us to
identify and to annotate the EEG
activity anchors and the boundaries of
all the EEG or all the other
or concepts but we still need to
understand what are the attributes
associated with its eg activities and
what are the types of the other medical
concepts as well as what are their
polarities and modalities this is
accomplished by developing two other
deep learning architectures so you see
in the slide that we have one
architecture that would identify all the
attributes of the ECG activities or the
16 ones that we have discussed before as
well as the mortality and the polarity
the second architecture is identifying
the type of medical concepts divided
into medical problems or each event or
treatments with tests as well as the
modality and the polarity you can note
that these architectures are very
different because of the fact that this
time by using a deep rectified linear
network which is using itself five fully
connected leaders of rectified linear
units so why we decided on using this
architecture why does it work very well
and how does it really work the decision
of using this fully connected layers of
rectified linear units was based on the
incredible properties that this unit
provides so I'll call them really from
now on so very rules are known that they
allow for a very is deep net
configuration but they also have a
sparse representation that allows them
to perform the facto internal features
selection with other words when you
learn this multi task
embedding in this architecture you are
actually learning selection of the
optimal features in identifying each of
the attributes of the each activities or
in identifying each of the types of
medical concepts that you want to
annotate so the sixteen
attributes are identified by filling the
shared embedding into a separate
software layer for each of the
attributes and the same thing happens
for the two software layers identify the
medical concept lives and their modality
and polarity so instead of training tens
of classifiers are actually having only
two people learning architectures that
perform very accurate annotations on a
very large set of eg reports and they do
that with learning the optimal features
that need to be selected well as we
develop these two types of deep learning
architectures we want to incorporate
them in the active learning loop the
active learning loop starts with this
vast collection of media reports on
which manual annotations were performed
and as shown examples of how they look
like
but those annotations become initial
training data for the two types of deep
learning architectures that we just
presented these architectures then are
used to annotate the thousands and
thousands of reports automatically and
then we need to have some sampling
methods to decide which of them we
should present a neurologist expert for
validation and editing and this enhances
the training initial training sessions
and they annotate the entire corpus
again I want to note here on the right
hand side that the active learning group
is the one in which you have an expert
going and validating the results of the
deep learning annotations and provides
retraining data and in order of making
the best use of the expert you need to
develop some sampling methods and the
sampling methods that we have developed
are taking into account that one make
many types of annotations as we needed
to combine a rank combination protocol
that would combine the civil single
tasks active learning selections into
one for this we develop a usefulness
score for each unvalidated annotation
from the eg reports and calculated it
with the kind of rank it would allow to
have the highest usefulness in to the
neurologist experts also experimented
with some Shannon entropy in developing
with sampling methods so the sampling
message in the methods enable the usage
of the active learning which would be
more accepting and editing the
annotations and then retraining the deep
learning methods and develop a new
system how does it work
well on the left hand side here you see
the learning curves of all the
annotations so if you take for instance
the first 100 eg report reports that
were annotated and evaluated you see
that for instance that the boundary
detection very quickly improves from we
start from an S score of 85% and we very
quickly go to about 90% only from a
small set of 100 reports the eg anchor
is being more complicated it is
interesting to see that we start again
from an F score of around 86 percent the
quality decreases initially but it
increases after a very small set of
annotations the attributes which were
not expressed in the anchors and
morphology showing the greatest increase
they are the most complex ones and we
start from a low around 67 f1 score and
we get to almost 75 X score in a very
few number of annotations which is also
expressed by the activity attributes
learning curve
now once that the EEG report annotations
are introduced what are we going to be
able to do with them we are looking at
two possible applications the first one
is to create an eejit specific qualified
medical knowledge graph in which which
can be used for medical question
answering there's a clinical decision
support as well as for various medical
probabilistic inference problems like
learning the posterior distribution of
clinical correlation given an EEG
description alternatively the eg report
annotations enabled us to create a
semantically rich index of clinical DG's
and also incorporate the ages signal
data in order to retrieve patient
cohorts so I'm going to focus on the
second application now the energy report
annotations would enable us to create
the semantically rich index because for
every medical concept that we
automatically identify we can generate a
separate unique identifier along with
the identifier will generate the concept
type for instance is an activity and it
is a sharp and slow wave and if it is a
concept that uses multiple terms then
each term would receive its own term ID
for the eg activities will also organize
all the attributes and the terms that
are used to express those attributes
that would generate what we call medical
concept dictionary this medical concept
dictionaries can also be associated with
their IDs into a term dictionary because
in information retrieval we generate
term based dictionaries so every term ID
that was found associated with every
medical concept ID would be expressing
the term dictionary and that's where we
associate the polarity that we have
discovered along with the concept in
which the term was used anytime we have
a positive polarity
indicate what each you report that term
was found in which section in which
position in the section what was the
concept medical concept ID in which it
appeared and what was the actual concept
and their mortality if it was a negated
concept that it will represent it with
similar information but in a different
list an information retrieval we use
dictionaries and also posting fast so
now I'm going to put my information
retrieval researcher hat on I will
discuss well how can we search for
relevant patients and how can we really
be able to use this index in the best
way so we first need to create inverted
theatres list so what I imported till is
they make sure that every time when you
find for instance a concept like a
seizure you'll be able to know all the
EG reports in which they are encountered
so we'll have tilt inverted list for
every positive polarity indication of
seizure as well as another set of
inverted list for every negative
indication of a seizure in which you see
that we have the term dictionary it's
like seizure but we'll also know that
that specifically to turn belong to a
medical concept ID in this case a
medical problem that is encountered in
some Asian port but as you remember from
two weeks ago that the Bitcoin showed
that this each report are associated
with every eg signal and their
processing so we like to be able to also
use this other modality that shows the
actual test and we created some eejits
signal fingerprints that are also linked
into the third inverted lists that would
enable us to search
the patients that we are interested as
based on the criterias of the cohorts
the EEG fingerprints are also organized
in a similarity hierarchy so how does
this work well the energy fingerprints
are generated by taking into account the
eg Sigma includes dense floating-point
metrics based on the number of
electrodes challenged that were used as
well as the number of samples in the
recording so when we did one pass over
all the edges signals we found that this
requires an enormous amount of
information just for one signal we will
need to have more than 4 gigabytes 400
gigabytes of information therefore for
the multimodal index we have to consider
a more compact representation of these
EEG fingerprints this compact
representation was created by another
deep learning architecture so now you
see a third
exemplification or deep learning in
which all the eg signals are processed
in very short time instead of processing
them in weeks and weeks we are
processing them in a test of hours
because we reduced the aegis signal from
20 megabytes to just a few hundred bytes
that was possible by using the recurrent
neural network that you see on the slide
in which we consider that every edge is
signal is actually a sequence of samples
such that for every sample we learn how
to predict the next sample and this was
made possible by using again the long
short-term memory cells that would learn
long range interactions in the ages
signal so the long short-term memory
cells maintain and update an internal
memory such that they can output the eg
fingerprint
after
they look at all the samples so once
that we have created this complex
multi-model index we can answer natural
language queries that express the
criteria for patient cohort for instance
if a neurologists would like to answer
to find a query of patients that take
top year I'm topiramate topo max with
the diagnosis of headaches and an EEG
demonstrating South wave spikes or
spiteful Skype and wave activity the
deep learning methods that process the
clinical text will be able to annotate
its query I recognize a top row might
topple max our test our medicines and
that headache is a problem and the edge
is a test assault wave spikes and spy
whole skies are eg activities once that
the analysis of the query is being
performed from the indica for
description we'll be able to use two
relevant models that take into account
the term or the concept dictionary that
we have discussed as well as the
imported list to enable the recognition
patient cohorts so we experimented with
two cases one case in which we use only
the annotations on the clinical texts
and another case in which we augmented
those annotations with the index that
consider the signal as well therefore
the multimodal index and we were
pleasantly surprised that this relevance
model showed that the model multimodal
index produced the better cohorts so in
order for finding this conference we had
to develop relevance models in
information retrieval there's this be
m25
ranking function that enables you to
find the most relevant documents or eg
reports that would match a certain query
if we are considering also the signal
fingerprint then we had to develop
another relevance model in which we
could look up the most similar eg
fingerprints for the top-ranked reports
provided by the PM 25 ranking function
so we asked then several neurologists to
provide with patient cocco descriptions
which we call queries and here you see
five examples of descriptions that they
all agree that would be of high clinical
interests for them and then we passed
those queries through our patient over
retrieval system and asked them to
evaluate the results so for every
patient Coover criteria we identify the
ten most relevant AG reports and then we
did a random sample of ten other reports
that were retrieved between the ranks of
eleven and 100 each neurologist was
asked to judge whether each of the eg
report was considered relevant they
would give a rank of one if the patient
is scribe in the report this definitely
belongs to the cohort they were looking
for and a zero if the patient does not
belong to and then we use three measures
that are widely accepted in the
information retrieval community to
evaluate the quality of the results
these measures are the mean average
precision the normalizes counted
cumulative gain and the precision at
rank ten and here are the results so if
we would have used only the clinical AG
reports with no processing of the
medical concepts then we would have
obtained a precision of ten at about
eighty percent and as you see the map
which we have defined the mean average
precision would be only about 52% if we
would have used some language models in
we would have tried to create
molarity based on statistical properties
between the query and the age Awards
actually the mean average precision
would have been even worse and as a
third baseline if would have used just
simple text processing the math the
median average precision would have been
46% therefore less than half of the
cases the patient would not have been
relevant our multimodal
patient retrieval system which we call
mercury obtained much better results
because we were able first to introduce
the medical concept dictionary so we
obtained average precision of 658 to 57%
when we also introduced the signals this
average precision jump to 70% but I also
want to know this other metric which is
the precision attendant which means the
10 most relevant patients and please
note that in the case when we use the
signals as well as the processing of the
AG reports worked in a precision of 100
percent meaning that the first 10
patients are always in the call ways
evaluated this should have belonged to
the cohort when we have used only the
annotate automatically produce
annotations on the eg report the
precision at 10 was 90% meaning that out
of 10 patients 9 should have been in the
cohort and 1 is incorrectly included in
a relevant cohort so in summary I hope
that I have convinced you that using
deep learning on big data can be
transformative because active learning
can take advantage of this Mars
successful deep learning architectures
and approaches to produce annotations
and in the case when adequate sampling
mechanism are considered in the active
learning group also neural learning
enables a large number of annotation
tasks
perform jointly and provides a very rich
somatic information to be captured in a
global manner across vast clinical
resources we believe that deep learning
can play an important role because data
wrangling it's critical because this
lack of annotated data and there's many
applications which will not support the
development of annotated Big Data
resources they are developed for a small
number of reports and a small number of
types of concept that we aim to annotate
annotations is just an enabler for many
applications for instance searching
through newly annotated data we'll also
have to consider all these modalities
sometimes we have text narratives but
also I have are the kind of signals or
images associated with them and has the
clinical information is to be organized
into a multimodal index which can be
generated with novel deep learning
representations the annotations produced
with deep learning in vast clinical data
will enable the generation of
probabilistic representations of medical
knowledge which will give a new impetus
to probabilistic medical conference I
want to acknowledge the grant that made
possible our research this is research
supported by the human National Human
Genome Research Institute the National
Institute of Health and the one
number-one u01
hg 0 0 846 for this research wouldn't
have been possible without the
incredible corpus of AG reports and
signals from the Temple University
Hospital any opinions are conclusionary
recommendations are only the authors and
do not reflect the views of National
Science Foundation or
National Institute of Health and if you
want to find more about me or you want
to learn and read the papers that I have
discussed here please
go to this URL that you see in on the
slide and here are some papers that I
touched on when describing the methods
here the first paper that describes
exactly deep learning architectures has
been submitted to the clinical research
informatics at emia
the second paper was just presented in
November at the annual symposium of a
Mia if you want to know more about the
corpus please go and visit the Temple
University Hospital Egypt data corpus
which was published in the frontiers of
neuroscience and if you want to find
more about um natural language
processing can be applied to medical
question answering for clinical decision
support we had a paper this fall in the
CI km conference which was awarded the
student best paper award and also have
upcoming paper on using deep learning
from eg big data for inferring
unspecified information in EDG reports
so I would be glad to take questions now
so Hyderabadi thank you so much for
being with us here today I mean I you
know you're taking in time away from
your day job as a professor and we
really appreciate it
this is this work is fascinating it
seems like it's very much related to
your big data to knowledge grant
wondering what other applications do you
see of this because certainly the
methods that you've talked about and the
usage of deep learning and all these
different in these in multiple ways for
the same
you know towards the same goal but using
it multiple times seems to be a very
novel way of doing things but yet also
very could be applicable and other in
other applications the types of problems
what do you see
doing next after this what do you see as
the next step well what that would be
very interested is in using these
methods and probably developing new
methods to be able to do clinical
decision support and being able to
identify how all these annotations can
be used to inform question answering
methods that are trying to find similar
cases in literature especially as we
have so many publications being
generated on a monthly basis and could
inform a clinical decision support
another important application would be
this creation of a very vast
probabilistic knowledge base and sharing
it with the community especially the
machine learning community that is in
big need of having resources to apply
for probabilistic inference and creating
actor prize that would be able to give
us priors of all these clinical
correlations and of similarities between
patients another application that we
have discussed with our friends at
Temple University is the ability to
detect in real-time seizures and this
kind of very complex public knowledge
base will be able to inform very much
best predictive methods that we could
develop on the data that we annotate in
any kind of corpus this is not
necessarily related to AG's any kind of
quarters that would have any kind of
clinical
and would have eventually any kind of
other modality like images could be
processed with this base methods with a
little extra work of tweaking the
annotation schema with the specific
problems that the corpus is covering I'm
glad you mentioned that one of the next
steps is doing the inference on here
because one of the questions online is
about how you'll account for uncertainty
but in particular how do you on count
account for that uncertainty in the data
as it's collected or that it's like
exactly so we know that this data is not
perfect so it may contain errors and it
has a lot of uncertainty definitely so
there are two ways that we have in mind
so the first way that we study tackling
is try to infer the under specified
information so there's a lot of clinical
data that is not giving you the full
picture so there's a lot to under
specified things that are not discussed
that you want to discover as well the
other aspect of it is that once that you
have this public knowledge base you'll
be able to start using probabilistic
inference on it to be able to deal with
uncertainty in the knowledge base that
were constructing we are associating
this modality of knowledge we have more
than the three that I have discussed
here we have several attributes which
are values of uncertainty like if this
hypothetical is possible is it
associated with another patient and so
forth and all those kind of uncertainty
values coming from the inferences that I
detected in the narratives I used in
probabilistic inference to generally the
most likely outcome that you are looking
for from this very last very vast
knowledge base thank you and there's
another question online that's or a
couple of other questions really about
what kinds of cool
are you using in your research and tools
or data so for example are you using IBM
Watson or other tools are you using
pubmed central corpus as your data if
you could just say a little bit more
about the types of things that that have
been helpful to you okay so that's an
excellent question so first of all we
are using clearly for question answer
who are not using Watson because I have
a past work in question answering for
about 20 years I'm one of the authors of
a book on question answering so in my
lab there's a lot of expertise on
building question answering systems we
believe we can do it better because we
have our own tools of relevance of
natural language processing and the
ability to identify and pinpoint complex
questions and their answers so these are
our own tools and we actually want to
share them with the research community
these tools are now upgraded with this
deep learning methods some of them I
have described here the deep learning
libraries that we have used were
tensorflow from Google we experimented
with several others but we all settled
on tensorflow because we find that they
are very reliable and very well
documented also in terms of other
natural language processing method that
we are using by using the jeanja corpus
we make use of umls we make use of the
pubmed central archive in order to tune
the features that turn out to be most
informative to our methods and by the
way we would like to release a quite
soon a version of the patient cohort
retrieval in such a way that anyone
I could build their own patient cohort
on their own clinical data and also to
release this kind of multimodal indexes
that people can easily use in their
research for experiments so thank you
very much again we're out of time but I
just wanted to say that on behalf of
everybody on line who is muted and
camped talk that we really do appreciate
you coming and sharing a bit of your
expertise here and it was certainly
fascinating to hear about the use of
deep learning to automatically annotate
the EEG reports and to retrieve relevant
reports so thank you
Thank You Michelle thank you for giving
me the opportunity all right
good bye all